みんなやばい気づいたらもう
2015年が終わり相談
4発中にはそっち行ロンブーボイパこちらネットろーっ
に言っててうけよえっ porter ドローポッドフルで楽しめるということでよく
わからないんですけど
ポケットに入るドローンみたいな住まいですよおそらく世界で一番小さい撮ろうかも
しれないです
おそらくそうで僕は今まで様々な感じ紺系のこういうのを紹介してきたんです
ん
さっ劇平気だな押せば
バージョンやうどん good ああああっ
わー今回でも最初で一番小さいをゲット外科れるって事も大変ってずに持ち上げたいの
で地上的には2つあげてみましょう
ブーバカメこんな本当になっておりますこれでしょ
これって事でしょうーこれ本当目の
破っにょきなんですけどって殺す
パコガードから変えるようなプロペラですうんうんペットになにこれはちょっと待って
色々と知らないものがちょっと雨のため
ば城端知らないのが多いよこれちょっつけなきゃいけないのかこれちょっと取り付け
ないといけないポイントに付けます ok ok こんな感じでございますこれでおか
なければヘリコプター反省です
問題はこれが飛ぶかどうかなんですよね飛ばし方がボスまた充電でしょ
俺知ってるよ
3ですねはいはいワロスワロス連中どうですかああここですかねはいオッケーぺー
なんでか2つある4つ多いんだよ炭酸4つめるちょっと短眠がタッチングちゃん説明
とってきた
アークガーデン芸を開きてきたみたいだ
なにこれただ充電がないからまた飛ばないですねこれで充電するんですよねこっちの
ランプが引いたら充電完了協議でございますしばしお待ちを
ふーんもう待てないプンプンする博はこれでちょっと蹴っ飛ばしてみましょう
おそらく世界最初の泥がどこ全くことができるのかもういい喉あれ
あれっあれっ全然わかんない
パターン3フォア大きい供給量が業界いうか下向きにした状態で今度は ok これで
はぷ
ああああああ
待って発泡性軽いは待った
糖尿病件東京件
頑張って
おおっこれはの女侠コントロールできる富山俺レベル6本できるよ
これねーよ絶対コントロールできるよ voodoo
はぁっ
ばーんっま絶対変えるのはに持っているです
ああああああ
ああああああああ
相当すごい
jr ん
います
しています